yo tout le monde sait ce quiz
aujourd'hui on se retrouve projet à
plusieurs parodies des avenants état de
folie
et oui je parle en rythme avec même un
jeu très intéressant on commence tout de
suite avec femme nathalie bikini bottom
donc a blanchi bob l'eponge quoi audio
il était là mais pourquoi la porte était
fermée où ces mecs ça prend un max de 1
mc cahill et la barre yann droite
annonce est nul à chier voilà je
décroche alors qu'est-ce qu'il dit le
moment où il a pris sa meilleure voie
c'est chiant ce qui l'est en battant
même les proches c'est bien faire du
sein d'un bon voilà vous avez compris
ses bienfaits de manière modérée [ __ ]
j'ai vu carlo j'ai vu son nez james hook
rené defossez de la porte
vas-y celle du 20 mai c'est la fête quoi
y'a tout bikini bottom qui utilisent
surtout fait de moi ce n'est pas du
touch pour vous commencé il ya tous un
parallèle que le zinc à son tour mais je
mens pas des barbes à papa moi bordel
ils sont trois tailles ce téléphone
pourrait que j'ai vraiment la touche
ferme ta bouche c'était avec karl de ses
pattes et qui fusionne hop là j'ai eu
patrick hop là j'ai vu ses yeux pervers
la plus tard j'ai pas mille du bia jamie
un bon gros jean baggy absolument rien
ne nous l'ont sur mon corps aujourd'hui
plus sa cage avec du pain saigner comme
ça délire sa moustache du klaxon ok on
est maintenant sur fight night hightower
rio qui lui pour le coup elle a vraiment
bien fait c'est parti new game 3 mois ou
à rio il nous affrontions fais pas le
malin il fait sur fois mon poids et d
une fois l'histoire d'un mec qui
s'appelait mario il travaille dans un
fast food
tu as comme par hasard on se demande
pourquoi un jour les deux versions ont
disparu et ont ils n'ont jamais
est ce qu'ils sont quelque part à ben
voila je me retrouve bordel la voyais
beaucoup plus sympa à écouter quoi il
sait pas donner à ce titre vous
rejoignez l'une minul wario nous attend
on n'a qu'à des petites batteries on
doit tenir jusqu'à 6h du mat je crois
c'est fou comme observé des wario comme
ça waluigi pardon c'est pas vrai du tout
en vert on reconnaît tester wario à haut
niveau de la brioche à lloret voilà deux
kilos de plus mais où sont-ils jeu en
hausse très marquée mois louise il est
passé au final avec ses grandes jambes
peut pas le rater ce grand dadais à
wario n'a plus de pupille un sas a
disparu cdi les amis d'henri burger qui
est préparé ça donne la gerbe de fer
gauche droite gauche gérant le vomi
c'est l'oculus mais sans le réalisme est
juste avec la gerbe et ben voilà mais ce
n'est même pas venue jusqu'à moi mais où
êtes vous je vous cher show et la [ __ ]
regarder il fait là il fait presque à la
hauteur du plateforme paloise avait
plafond mais bon ou là c'était confus et
c'est luigi via l'outil qui sera ma
fille qu ils n'ont pas pu mettre petit
chat à sannois houdaille zpux avec de
l'homme bien viril à la moustache mais
c'est vrai qu'ils sont tous moustachu à
wario et aux toilettes voilà où les
frais réparé seyfried ccoc y en a un qui
passe me voir au bureau comme ce fut
longtemps la la on aurait pu jouer chez
paula sur cet écran oh ça m'a réveillé
d'un coup sec
un passionnant au lu un truc dans la
gorge c'est warrios à une lance des
frites
alors est-ce qu'il ya pitch un jour on
veut pitch en mode yeux luigi posséder
avec le nez de carlos au monde 2010 ils
ont tous eu des carences en fait dans ce
jeu o o plein offert de le voler ok on
attend il enchaînera avec quoi alors
hausse et ce partout où ils sont là les
quelques bugs mais battant [ __ ] mais
parler de tout cela
sap a voilà au moment où je vais faire
ça à chaque fois sans jamais regarder ça
oui déjoue montrent ils sont plus là
c'est qu'on a moqué par donc regarder ça
regarde c'est une fin
regardez sa garde des sceaux a
on y revient à lui oscillé revenir le co
est maintenant sur fall n'attaque frais
de labyrinthes et la particularité dans
celui-là c'est qu'on peut se déplacer à
hôtel au plateau et à gaines adams est
super non là un espace au [ __ ] c'est
stylé par contre là en boîte ne va
quitter déjà là où vous l'avez vu c'est
ce qu'on donne quoi regardez il est là
il est juste là mais je frime de la
fumée ce qui se passe jean-michel en
direct duarte qui se réfugie aux
toilettes et femmes emmerdes aux cuvées
ne court pas ne crie pas ne fait pas
qu'est qu'un parterre non c'est les
règles pour notre sécurité quitter
l'endroit avant qu'il fasse noir est bas
moins il fait noir je suis en plein
dedans quelques années et qu'est ce tu
sens s'est fait avaler ce que je
pourrais être effectué sous la table ou
sûr que je peux ah non moi tu peux
mettre en foetus dans la table donc en
plus efficaces ou rd je me mets direct
dans le masque je crois qu'on a fini le
jeu et du coup on est bien on sur ay
nous à feu au lac et au hockey tapas
espagnoles girondins le groupe genevois
moi je trouve ce gameplay passionnant et
les zooms à quoi ils servent
on les connaît à la casse fin du mois ça
me casse couilles mais j'ai une
poussette virilité si vous dire à quel
point ça me saoule et nous sommes
maintenant sur one night at floyd est ce
que j'aime bien déjà c'est que c'est
qu'une nuit donc ça va être cool aller
de nuit chez wario on s'en souvient au
[ __ ] les cards ont bien fait cela a le
plaisir le plaisir après ces défis
auxquels on vient de jouer au hockey on
se bat les déchets mais bon voilà bien
mieux par exemple la sicav mon bien fait
quoi c'est eux qu'on craint c'est ça
qu'on doit craindre quand même celui
d'hier
regardez le ou d'oie craintes à quoi
voulez-vous craindre 9 au 11 parce que
vous croyez
j'essaie juste de voler mon et regarder
à ses volets sont clos j'ai beaucoup
plus réaliste étant donné le bordel du
bureau du mec ça c'est un vrai bureau on
est d'accord c'est tous comme ça chez
nous oh le con et m20 vous montrer ses
dents comme eva temps on a vu ton père
peut-être orthodontiste mais c'est pas
une raison
voilà surtout quand tu en as un mec elle
est dangereuse dégueulasse 2 heures du
matin il nous reste les deux tiers de la
batterie oh mon dieu mais moi j'aime
beaucoup lui je pourrais lui faire bonne
et j'ai envie d'ouvrir matin mais a dû
faire un canard bas il s'est barré
voulait pas de mon canard fdp c'est pas
mal
c'est quoi ça tout mignon du coup là il
reste deux heures et on a un tiers la
batterie ça peut passer
pense qu'on va être rade de batterie
pourtant je fais que de faire ça la jupe
est un gars tort que d'avoir peur d'un
[ __ ] castor j'étais à fond je pensais
vraiment pas réussir je suis deux
goûters et ben c'est quoi je vous
propose qu'après cette perfection en
face le pire de tous vous savez déjà en
voyant cette image que c'est à partir en
couille croyez moi que là on est dans le
très très lourd chargement des images
qui font peur déjà rien que ça ça va pas
du tout trahi euros auxquels toute
chaîne jeu caméra c'est fait avec des
images réelles donc d'un mec qui a pris
les photos chez lui par gomis et 10 mois
tapis de course et un moins effrayant
reste al chourouq into the hole espace
touche à une flash lite j'appuie tac
voyez le tocsin âge vos charges épices
d'accord mais les gars juste un moment
on parle de qualité on parle pas de
qualité à la belle romaine un peu bas
dans pareille joie est le petit effet de
lumière au fond ça ferrat c'est moyen
vraiment démontré fois les caméras
pas du tout adorent mais on voit très
bien ce 2 mai à fâcher avec l inde et la
flèche le nombre de liens mec là y'a un
mec là le mec il est juste là oh mon
dieu
vous avez vu stade club de golf qui
volent et [ __ ] j'suis pas au club de
golf on aurait dû se méfier au regard d
une araignée quoi mais qu'at il donc
j'aimerais tellement que la revoir mais
quoi sur le tapis de course comme ça
serait très heureux de l'arrivée juste
la ola eu beaucoup sur les voies la
poussière cassuto sutton tombe j'aurais
pu parler
or audio au le malaise
je vous jure je me sens pas bien quoi la
vaisselle rd c'est génial quoi bon avec
habillés en noir de dos comme ça c'est
fantastique
il faut vraiment qui retient la
poussière sur son pc mais vraiment après
que tu pourras plus faire de jeu superbe
comme ça par exemple à regarder ya
l'arrivée sur le lit opus est grillé que
c'est une fausse elle a des gros points
entre les articulations quoi au ccf en a
je suis décédé one ont justement dans la
science et la foi de cette d2 sur ces
petites versions différentes et bon pour
ça c'est une parodie c'est clair et net
c'est une parodie de fawe natale froid
dit j'espère ça vous a plu si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude comme vous pouvez le voir
aujourd'hui on a tapé dans la qualité
souvent des gens me disent que je
devrais faire des vidéos sur des jeux 2
me de plus grande qualité est bon
aujourd'hui je les ai écoutés ces gens
là voilà merci à vous regarder en soit
on se réveille de sa prochaine vidéo
vous savez quoi faire avec vos deux
doigts tu as tout le monde dit ça et toi
ton chien dans la vraie vie fais pas ça
dont il te regarde respectueux et donne
toujours plus de croquettes jour après
jour six de chaque job incroyable